how did this match come to be so you see
there's this thing called discord and i
have eric rosen added on discord
one day i was like hey eric do you want
to play a match against me
and he was like yeah sure nemo when do
you want to play and i'm like how about
sometime next week
and he's like yes that sounds good
please let me know what time works for
you
and i was like okay how about wednesday
at 5 p.m it was like okay see you then
that's how it came to be okay i am rosa
um
okay i'll 3-0 i'll make it unrated
because my rating is really low right
now
i mean if you want to fire me i'm not i
don't want to i'm going to lose rating
yeah i could farm you i don't know
that's true i mean
we can do it raided but also like
it's okay it's okay we already have our
egos online i think that's enough
okay that sounds like enough for me yeah
sounds good
all right best of luck we'll call after
the three minute portion
okay good luck all right good luck bye
bye
okay sorry if the audio was off i i
wasn't um
paying so so close attention to the the
levels
um oh what did i prepare i prepared
taimana
first let me close all my tabs too
uh okay okay should be good
okay deep breath oh i prepared jalalabad
too
oh she's playing uh she's playing
something a bit quieter
um did chess weave teach her this
wait a minute let me think for a moment
here
i'm gonna play um look at this and
we're gonna have a more kind of closed
sicilian position
um i spent a lot of time the first like
five moves
but uh okay finding some groove
we'll play play b6 maybe go for d5
and yeah she wants to play this so
play rook e8 and probably go bishop h8
still want to play d5 eventually
i think i want to take and then
it looks scary like the whole king side
is
um it looks a little bit delicate but
the bishop covers f6
uh there's another five which is a move
uh then we can trade
i don't mind that actually i guess she
has bishop g5 but then f6
wait a minute it takes takes
i think it's okay this bishop might get
stuck especially after f4
yes i'll take opening the file now both
sender files are open
um down on time
queen queen d7 is natural
i'm gonna stay focused here
oh thank you nylon r yeah i appreciate
all the support
the 10 donation too um
from earlier okay so what to do
i like the position overall but
i just want to i want to max my maximize
pressure
i think i'll offer the trade of bishops
and then try and get the knight either
into e3 or to f6
[Music]
um
and g4 is one plan
do i play f6 right now it's a funny move
oh i could because then 93 is coming so
i have a double threat
i'm down a minute
position's good though let's take
and i should offer the trade
no let's um
make her think if i play this and
easy move for white
and now we'll do this
oh there's a trap or is there no
but maybe bishop e4
first
okay this is a beautiful position
i want to play rook c2
okay stay calm
i mean there's so many good options or
good looking options that it's hard to
choose sometimes the move to go for
uh let's just push upon i just want to
keep moving quickly and try and make up
the time
deficit a4 okay i had rook c1
knight d3
here we trade
oh wait a minute play this
move
let's play rook a1
are you going to defend it's not so easy
to win with the time situation
h6 and g5
i know she's fast
okay here we go so now i win the thing
oh wait what oh she resigned and i would
have blundered my queen
i thought queen of three was made she
resigned before i could actually blunder
my queen
that's so funny no one tell her
wow okay
man i got nervous there i was low on
time
what a start to the match
yeah she wouldn't she wouldn't know like
um obviously it was losing her
for white but oh she wants to do things
i feel like she prepared for my london
okay we'll play one of these
i want to start okay so i have to manage
my time better
um if she's playing bishop g4 i'm gonna
mix up the move order next game
wait did she fall for this trap last
time she may have
i vaguely remember like getting her with
this bishop a6 idea
um there should be seven is a better
move
so there's certain variations where the
queen will
win the bishop
um and already like if rook c8 here i
take
rook takes i bishop b5
maybe now i can win a pawn
and this is uh rook beats prevented
oh thank you uh thanks to so many people
um if i have a time advantage maybe i'll
read off
people who are subbing ashton reese
trying to learn one two three four uh
flavordaver
and yeah thanks everyone
i guess everyone previously too that's a
good move
if i
yeah let's just do this typical london
stuff
hmm
i didn't want to allow bishopdix d2
so
now holding my ground two moves away
from castling
palm structure is a little bit ugly
oh i should have played bishop e2
wait this is just not a good position
because f4 is in box control
have some idea of this g6 would be nice
for me
let's back up
preventing queen c2 i probably just
wanna like hunker down
it's a really sad move like just
completely undeveloping
but i want a pawn
i'm just holding on for dear life
now the idea is to play queen d3
i might not end up casting this game
like the rook might come here
she's gonna attack on the b file too
okay but i do have a time advantage
king d1 it's such an ugly move but
yeah e5 is coming
okay i'm gonna run the king and then
kind of fake castle on the queen side
i let's i could no
what do i do here
yeah i'm getting crushed
uh maybe rook and just say goodbye to
the
h pawn gonna try and prevent the d-file
from opening
[Music]
this is really bad play this move
okay maybe trade queens
okay at least i have a position i can
work with
so attack something e2 is still covered
attack the bishop attack the pawn
put the work on each file maybe
before perhaps
kind of weakening move but we're going
to start pushing
oh my rook
my brook is just trapped this move
trying to be tricky let's go
tricks are for kids but also for
whatever i am okay
let's play this
uh wait my time
i'm queening with chuck
let's go
okay oh that was really close she
outplayed me
completely and then i guess i was tricky
enough
okay rematch
i mean these games are so stressful okay
the first game i was better and then
i almost didn't win and then that game i
was much worse
um but somehow one okay um
what did i prepare oh yeah let's let's
go in into at least one stafford
she's probably prepared this time
oh okay let's play this so she's just
avoiding the saffron but we're getting
um
a reverse fried liver
wait i don't know this line
this is exactly reverse fried liver
she doesn't play e5 as
as black so she hopefully she doesn't
know the theory here
um there are some like carlson wesley so
chessable course type thing
um yeah i know this move is like the
trendy thing people do these days
okay so i'm out of any sort of prep
but i am up a pawn that's the one good
thing about this opening
is it's kind of up to white to get
compensation
maybe queen h4
it's actually very pleasant because the
structure is a bit off for white too
his pawn's attacked
oh can i take on h3 and play queen f4
it's almost winning
but there's rookie one oh also our
she was just taking my bishop never mind
but it's an idea just to keep in mind
can i trap the knight
b5
ah so everything's so close to working
let's start with b5
make the light move backwards
i was thinking b4
i'm just trusting instinct as takes
takes takes
maybe i don't have anything
wait a minute can i take
it's getting weird she could take here
it takes
etc i also play this move threatening
bishop a6
i think i'll just go for this oh
yeah that was less expected but also
looks playable
okay i'm gonna be tricky threatening
bishop a6
yeah it's a nice kind of skewer kebab
not sure what my thread is maybe
nightier
so the queen's tied down to the bishop
bishop's pinned to the rook
yeah there was some nice double skewer
kebab
okay i think i'll be up the exchange
because both bishops are hanging
so we could trade she could take cure
but i'd take and then the knights pinned
put the bishop back
okay so i'm down on time but position is
very good
maybe this move
actually that maybe doesn't work a4
because the pawn was attacked
okay i want to play f5 i think maybe now
it's more playable
so if takes i take on e2 first
wow
confusing position
that's a good move
now my time whoa it's regretful
chlamydia thanks for gifting subs
regretful chlamydia good to see you
okay i have to stay focused
so if takes i mean the rook's ready to
come to e1
[Music]
anytime i could try and simplify there's
also this idea c5
it's not hang a queen
um take your first
oh let's check i forgot let's check
no okay i'm kind of losing here
and down on time
can i pull some more dirt
no that was a mouth slip
i'm just dead
yeah all my pieces
um i was hoping she would pre-move some
pawn move there
yeah i got needed
so the hope is that um they pre-move
this because if i queen the pre-move
gets canceled
so like promoting to rook is uh the hope
well played yeah i've um
i mean i made one mouse slip but i was
already kind of worse
um okay let's play play e4
what did we go into last time
oh i played london the um the previous
game
wait she plays e5
i'll play ponziani
oh i remember i trapped her uh last time
in ponziani
there was some fun um trap where
yeah she took the the pawn she took the
pawn
and then i um
i played d5 and won the knight but she's
not falling into it this time
okay so we're gonna have a more kind of
solid position
oh thanks so much regretful chlamydia
says love your content and love this
community
i love you and the community as well i
really appreciate that
i play queen b1
so she wants to play f5 which is kind of
a
very thematic move queen b1
also this move the drawback of this move
is if takes takes as knight b4
so if takes all take with knight
and here okay now i'm preparing to take
back with pawn
knight before zen prevented
i don't know where my rooks should
should go maybe b4
or rook t1 when in doubt align your rook
with
the opponent's queen
like in general you should put your
rooks ooh she wants to hurt me
you should put your rooks on files which
might become open
just play king h2 here
knight c4 is a legal move
so i'm throwing the pawn three times
it's defended three times now
and queen e2
a lot of pieces just kind of clustered
on the king's side
[Music]
so throwing in takes doesn't work knight
a5 is kind of interesting
there's knight d2 play knight a5 so i'm
attacking the pawn
when i play b4 and this is
kind of a decoration it looks pretty but
it's not really doing much
i'll play b4 maybe prepare c4
wait are we playing ten games total or
first to ten i forget
i think it's first to ten
okay so this is nice actually because
now my bishop's gonna open up
um this pawn's gonna be a long-term
weakness first to ten okay good to know
this move
and there's g6 oh but then i win the
pawn so it's a double attack
now it's another double attack
so if takes takes it's another double
attack but there's bishop f6
so i think oh she wants to pin me
but let's just take a pawn
so i'm up two pawns
down on time
oh prediction going i'm not going to
look at the prediction because i don't
want to be
influenced but it's probably
like win or lose also thank you gerch
subbing with prime
okay uh can we can i take
there's a lot of ways to convert this
maybe this move
just lift another piece into the attack
at some point i do want to sack i guess
i could have taken there
i probably should have an easy
calculation
okay we're gonna i'm just gonna play low
risk chess
i could even uh lift the rook up to h4
second attack
um i'm gonna do that but without the
sack
so i'll just attack yeah
okay that's nice um
i feel like that was the cleanest game
out of all the games
i avoided like severe time trouble and
i don't think i blundered too much that
game
uh what to play oh i'm gonna play the
jalalabad
no do i oh i can't even
if not f3 i was considering playing e5
i'll play one of these
b5
okay so this is what i like to play
against
close sicilian
um
yeah going to pressure the pawn
also thank you wallace pao
for the victory bits so this is a
typical move
very often the knight will come back to
h6 and then f5
it takes a lot of time but the position
[Music]
gets pretty closed so
um the fact that i'm moving my knight a
bunch of times
it's hopefully not going to be too
relevant in the grand scheme of things
and yeah this is a very typical setup if
white ever plays g4
i'll take and play knight h4
and this is usually what i'm going for
against close sicilian
when i play a6 on move two is this exact
setup
for the pieces um bishop a6 is pretty
typical
hitting d3
and keep building up kind of aligning
myself with the bishop
but it's also aligned with the king
there's some idea to play h4 g4 knight
g3
i have takes i would take with knight
interesting
i might play like some rook move like
rook b b8
just so the bishop's not pinned and i
might be threatening b3
[Music]
b3 here
it's interesting
or takes i don't know what to do
i'll play g6 because what else maybe
i'll put my king on g7
i just don't want to change things too
drastically because i do like the setup
this is typical just to get the rooks
connected
g4 is never coming because of the x-ray
vision
okay so pawns are very v-shaped
i'm going to leave the tension
because i'm not sure if i want to take
or push
anytime soon
and bishop here and then fight for the a
file
or bishop
[Music]
yeah she wants to double up
95 doesn't quite work
in b3
there might be some g4 in the end
i'm not sure what to do here i might
play b3
just make the rook move back
and then because there's these squares
are oh wait
but okay now they're all controlled so
we're have to move back
and now queen b7 and i'll fight for the
file
yeah she wants to play g4
interesting
okay so i'm getting the file very
positional game
g4 might happen
really building up here
my time
connect five yeah what to do maybe this
move
oh can i win oh my queen is trapped if
we're okay one
she didn't quite see it
i'm in trouble here
yeah she dirty uh but actually
she she played well because she was
winning too
well played very well played okay so
it's 2-3
oh okay that was i was kind of intense
let's play another london and this time
i'll
i'll mix up the the move order
because now with bishop g4 i have knight
e5 yeah
otherwise the knight would be pinned
i could have played i could still play
h4 here
there's some fun ideas
i think i'll play h4 here wait a minute
maybe i'll start with this
like there's already ideas of trapping
the bishop with f3 and
g4 h5
i played knight c3 to avoid bishop takes
b1
i don't want to give the bishop any
escape
now black could play bishop g6 g4 and
then h6 but then i
or h6 immediately um
but i can get good pawn structure
yeah this is this is really nice
e3 is also e4
and queen c2 will provoke king f7
so maybe i can start with queen c2 and
then e3 bishop d3
yeah this looks really nice
she would like to play g5 but after
takes there's a pin
oh forgot about that move
and it shouldn't be a big deal castle
so the knight and king are tied down to
the sad
um g6 pawn
it still takes work to to crack the
position i think you t drive
subbing at tier one
if i it's a good move
she wants to simplify just play king
here
if takes i'll take with pawn play king
a1
and then maybe if this bishop goes away
i can play this takes and win the pawn
yeah so if takes i'll play knight e2
and then just control the c file
this it's tough for black when the rooks
are not connected
so there's no works he ate hello hello
brix zero nine zero zero subbing for 26
months welcome back
it's been some uh yeah a lot of i've
been seeing a lot more subs like
subbing for over two years i do
appreciate the longevity
am i trapping the queen here here
it's close
i shouldn't take too much time here it's
just
okay let's start with a simple move
like these positions i sometimes need to
work at is
like when things are really good i just
have to keep playing quickly
keep the pressure
maybe e4
okay now we're going to pin from behind
because if rookie had i taken
that wins material and the thread is to
play
this
and king is really safe here
so we might see knight d7 and then then
the rooks get connected
over that move
huh might as well take first
make knight f4 i'm keeping all the
tension
just trying to maximize pressure
so now there's three attackers on g6
um let's take it
threatening made in one queen e7
[Music]
this is a cool move
[Music]
i just want a pretty mate
some really like cool mating
possibilities let's play this
first the king's really stuck still
i'll take
okay go for the back rank mate
oh no my rook checkmate okay
i didn't see a way to force it but i saw
a way to bait the bishop to move away
okay okay
and she was really low on time so that
worked out
um okay we're gonna play another
sicilian i guess i'll play
i'll play the jalalabad for the lolz
it's a jalalabad i haven't played
jalalabad in so long
how do you even play it this move it's
like a stafford but
you get a you can't develop your bishop
to c5
um but there's some you get some
development i guess in this line
probably not enough compensation for
being down upon
but it's something
trying to make this jalala good
so i wanna i'd like to castle queenside
but
i should just castle kingside
okay defending the knight
there's actually some compensation here
because this bishop is
a bit stuck my bishops are nice
bishop g5 probably coming a good move
so f6
also queen d7
there's cases where the bishop tries to
move back and then i play a quick
f5 f4 and then try and trap the bishop
for example if i get an h6 bishop h4
then mean she might end up stacking but
we'll see
yeah this is actually working out really
well because knight has to move
back and then i trap the bishop
okay it's jalala very good
oh she's gonna sack though
so what's the best way to do this
i could play this move i wonder if i can
play bishop f4
preserving bishop f4 there's knight h1
i mean let's oh there's my h5 too never
mind
huh maybe i'll play this first
no no let's just win the bishop
i was trying to be too fancy there
um my king will be a little bit naked
but there will still be attacking
potential on the king's side
like f4
[Music]
we're both trying to attack on the
king's side at this point
queen g7
a lot of it's about initiative like
making threats while
improving pieces whoa trying to learn
gifting five subs thank you trying to
learn
really appreciate that bishop f3
attacking the
counter-attack in the night let's play
this move
i hope you're learning something
um or trying to learn something
from these games i'm attacking the
bishop threatening maybe f
oh f4 is really nice f4 attacks the
knight and obstructs the queen
oh my knight defends the bishop
honestly didn't see that coming h4 is
probably coming next
my time is dwindling
what to do just trade no
let's start with rook f5 and then i'll
trade
so i induced a weakness with h4
maybe 95 just put everything in the
center
yeah i just kind of saw that i assumed
this move
i might lose f pawn but then win the h
pawn
so my queen is protecting my naked king
let's play this move
a rook here coming
oh triple four coming
i mean mainly this fork
she's gonna try and dirty flag me but
i'm threatening some kind of mate
i think
it's just mate next move unless she
takes
okay plenty of time
okay that was a fun game joe walla yeah
until lala success
will rematch okay
oh some people what was the prediction
prediction was about something
okay um play another one
of e4 if she plays this maybe i'll i'll
mix it up
i check her smith more games oh no i was
gonna play
i was gonna play this mcdonald attack
transposing into grand prix attack
so 97's wait bishop d7
kind of a new move
play this anyway i mean eventually i do
want to play
f5
oh she's really mixing things up i'll
play f5
one of the points is it takes i got the
d5 square for the knight
wow
a very bold decision um
huh
this move dazzles me it shouldn't be
good but i'm i'm slightly confused
maybe i'll play bishop f4 like target d6
and then go for knight b5
by the way this is um this is vitamin c
it's like water and the
um what's it called
emergency it helps boost my immune
system
yeah this not sponsored
in case people were wondering but i also
have tea green
um some kind of like honey green tea
okay so if takes and
i'll have some nice compensation
um this is probably the clear threat oh
there's a really cool
idea so if black ever plays d5
and i get in this and this i can say oh
no my queen and then
mate because the bishop will control
these squares
but it's uh yeah it's not gonna happen
it's kind of sad
before that's a good move because
c2 is attacked
i wonder if i can play knight e4 here
it's weird like in this opening i played
queen e1 with the intention of
attacking on the king side for when
black would usually castle king's side
but with queen e1 i also have the
possibility of queen a5
wait what oh knights can move backwards
okay let's play this move i didn't even
realize that was attacked
i saw this in this
but um okay this is nice because the
pawn's attacked
and this pawn is pinned to the mating
square
so i'm threatening
i was fighting knight c5
oh i could play this move
now that i've remembered knights moved
backwards
and i can say oh no my bishop but then
knight d5 and
i'd fork stuff um
so bishop c6 she's yeah she's being
aware of my tricks
bishop bishop g5
okay now i probably don't want to lose a
bishop
yeah how do i crack the position
i have to save the bishop just sadly
move here f6 and then move back
i didn't see i didn't see any
thing clear or better so i'm down on
time
i mean there's still some attacking
ideas my king is still quite safe too
just have to be more patient
oh takes in d5
so if takes i might play knight b5 first
try and keep things messy wow
let's play this move
these pawns kind of terrify me
i just have to pretend that they don't
exist and do my own thing
up on time
[Music]
hide in the corner
because i want to take and i don't want
this to be check
okay so now the idea is to black has
everything defended though
i might just win this on time
uh it takes maybe this move
there we go that was only one check
though
i want to lift the rope let's play g4
first
very thankful that was defended
that was i was a little bit too close
for comfort
i uh 15 now okay i'll set t
i almost flagged there i was really
close
yeah she played really well and really
quickly man
it was very unsettling okay um
i'll play a scandi keep mixing up the
openings
d4
wait what is this i guess this is
playable
okay we're just going to have some
simple developments
yeah i'll get kind of the the nice
scandi setup
trying to make john bartholomew proud
even though jon usually
takes on d5 of the queen
play a5 so if c4 i can play this move
some idea knight f4 as well
95's coming
let's do this make it interesting thank
you apple babel
subbing with prime also thanks to aj
chess and hey tj uh appreciate the the
prime subs
okay so talking
various things ooh
uh wait what oh
okay white has three defenders i have
three attackers
so we could trade a lot
hmm i played this move
i don't know what to do here takes
i could be normal in castle i'd just be
normal
i'll be normal for once i do like
castling for so long
but it's usually usually like not a bad
thing to follow principles
i think you already subbing with prime
so she wants to destroy my queen
um play knight knight d5 rook f3 i'll
always have the square for the queen
now it's a confusing center position
knights occupy 75 percent of the center
i might have knight f4 coming the rook
might be a target
oh you should be considering these moves
oh she's really close to trapping my
queen
okay not anymore also thank you andrew
rsk and red hot jacob yeah so many
people using their prime subs i do
appreciate it
to do here
i don't know what my plan is in life
i can play this by the four
a4
hikaru did this to me once like one of
the last times i played hikaru he just
did this and then destroyed me
i forget how though
i have to uncover suppressed memories
okay maybe i'll i'll try and milk like
both sides of the board
my queen side is nice lights pawns are
fixed
now i can maybe go for this idea
there's also a g5 g4
like a g if knight moves here
oh that would be a good move i was
thinking i could take and play g4
because this pawn is now kind of pinned
to the h2 square
oh time is good for me keep forgetting
about time
like the position distracts me from the
clock
so g4
and just put the rook somewhere oh maybe
e5
i don't know i'll put the rook here
first
now e5 whoa blunder prone gifting subs
thank you blender prone
oh no my pawn
i had tactics with bishop h2
okay oh no white spawn
wait this is good for me now because i
might win both pawns and win the queen
or just win one pawn
good move
oh
we both wondered there
oh another dirty flag man she's played
so well in these time scrambles
oh i'll let the heart rate cool down a
little bit
drink some more tea oh let's go again
okay
a lot of these games are coming down to
the the wire
um i'll try one of these maybe i'll play
c3 sicilian
oop never mind do i play
i'll play a four knights
um ah she's playing okay yeah she's
playing solid chess
i don't know what i play against this
maybe i'll play
i'll just play normal developing moves
whoa it's johnob thanks john hub
gifting 5 subs
do appreciate that
i'm doing my best to to stay focused
uh but yeah thanks to so many people for
being here
i do appreciate uh everyone
sharing positive vibes in chat
stay on this diagonal bishop b2 may have
been
more principled but i'm gonna play this
in a more kind of aggressive
attacking fashion
as i calmly move the king into the
corner
that's very typical when you play f4
like the king is happier here
my idea is probably to lift the queen
maybe at some point play f5 or knight f5
enjoy the space advantage
bishop b6 be coming if bishop a6 i'll
play this in this
one of the lifting moves now knight f5
hitting the bishop kind of
so c5 is probably going to come soon
yeah rookie it's a good move
not entirely sure what to do here
i think i'll play wait a minute
oh there's a really cool idea
maybe not i was envisioning like check
and then queen c4
but i don't think that would work
okay so i'm threatening to take the
knight and double the pawns
i don't think she can get away with this
okay i always have to be considering
bishop f7
queen here first and i have so many
pieces like aimed at the king side
if c5 i have knight b5
and then some like takes in queen b3
maybe
feels so close sad that you weren't in
the streamer team arena
leap school oh i think i was maybe busy
forget exactly when that was
okay so i'm contemplating sagging both
bishops
um it's probably dubious it looks so
much fun
i could play queen b3 immediately
and d5
not seeing it
if i take maybe i'll take on g7
oh my time i'll take on g7
it's probably dubious i mean the
position was so good there was no
great reason to sack but i mean this
might this might actually be good for
whites
knight's undefended aligned with a rook
f7 is a big big target now i can take
and
if rook takes i take the knight and
attack stuff
rook is pinned
okay this is turning into actually a
really nice attacking game
okay
okay yeah she didn't go for the dirty
flag um
i felt like it was still gonna take some
work but um
okay keeping some streak
um repeat one of these
maybe offer a stafford
god they have at least one stafford
right
i think she usually plays bishop e3 here
but she might be yeah she might mix
things up we'll see
um okay oh she was expecting king f2
too i wonder if she was
it seems like she's not oh this this is
a drawing line
i don't want to draw though this is
usually something i would play against a
gm
just just get an easy draw
uh
[Music]
i'm gonna play on for a win attack the
rook please play this
because it gets mated instantly
okay so this is uh objectively not good
for black
um so people should not try this at home
or at work just gonna leave all the
tension
have a small time advantage so i will
get
um i'll get the work eventually
and then i'll have a rook and a pawn
for two minor pieces i'm pretty sure
stockfish gives something like plus
two or three for white because white has
a bishop here uh maybe i can play this
first
just trying to drain her time
castle it's funny the rook still can't
move because it's meat
funny mating idea
but this is yeah it's beginning to be
just new territory
uh we'll repeat once more i'll play rook
e8
so there's some pressure against this
bishop
okay now i'll probably have to take the
rook
unless i can repeat again
but then bishop f2
there's also bishop d5
or queen e3 spending too much time here
i will go for this yeah that was a mouse
slip actually i meant to take but now
i'm hesitating
t4
i don't know
this actually looks more fun i'm gonna
be down a piece after it takes takes
takes takes but this rook is hard to get
out i
think
there's some queen e3 check idea
some rook lifting idea yeah so i kind of
saw
to this point like rookie one and i'm
not sure how white defends
actually i guess king f1
but the rook is completely stuck
this move oh queen f3 coming
[Music]
oh but i have queen g6 trapping the
bishop
only move i think or queen g5
okay so the bishop's trapped sees the
staffing gambit pawn structure is so
solid
okay
interesting if i play rook
i want to play rookie one i don't think
it works though unless it does
no too risky
not my time play this
so all i want to do is attack on the
kingside
g3i rookie 2 and then
if kg1 probably g5
play this i just want to chase the queen
off the diagonal
the queen g5 i don't know what i do
yeah what do i do here i have
discoveries that don't really do much i
guess i play this one with a pawn
somehow uptime
another time scramble and b4 is covered
take this thing b5
i know she's fast but i'm not on time
there we go
okay i think she's winning in the end
game that was a messy game
that was a weird game a stafford gambit
line man
it's a cool variation though because if
i had this position
let's say against takaru i can just
force a draw and why can't get out of it
so it's one way to equalize
wait rematch cool finish
oh thank you hey it's zippy welcome back
to bee
um i sent a rematch i think
oh okay game starting
cool um
yeah i want to do something fun maybe
king's gambit
yeah okay king's game of time i'm not so
well prepared but
uh we'll see what she plays ah so she's
sticking with the same kind of setup
bishop e6 interesting
yeah someone like before this match
started
told me to go for king's gambit
[Music]
ooh
i guess it'll be a sharper position
so
there's a lot of captures to consider i
don't think anything leads to
anything so i'll develop
sometimes it's best just to keep all the
tension
i am allowing this move after which i
probably move back
okay move into the corner
oh queen's gambit accepted uh well she
doesn't really play d4
so that might be hard to achieve
and i i checked her um her games against
d4 she plays queen's game declined
which maybe we'll have at some points
of this move still
actually i think i'll play this move
because i'll induce bishop takes b3 and
then i'll get the file
for the rook which is kind of nice
maybe this move
yeah we're gonna have the bishop and the
rook aimed at a7
[Music]
she doesn't really care about my i mean
the pawn's defended
so h6 is logical i kind of want a sack
queen d4
because knight c6 is queen a4
unfortunately there is b6 there
you can stack again okay one king b7
but then i'm down too much okay i'll
move back that's the move i should have
played just instantly
i'm having too much fun calculating okay
so i'm going to attack the pawn
probably inducing this and then we'll
try and trade off the
the main defender of the the king
i'm kind of blundering upon but
hopefully it's okay
b6 i win the a6 pawn
i'm not sure if this is actually a real
threat
it feels like it should be like the king
runs
there's some cool idea to like play
knight here and then
some combination of knight e5 or t1
[Music]
yeah good move
uh let's do
i mean i have to go in right
and g4 is probably coming
play this move
so i'm trying to remove the rook from
from the back ring so i can check and
win the other rook
easier said than done yeah i could move
oh but now maybe i can take oh i could
set up the pork
the majestic pork combination of a pin
and a fork did i miss eric play the
king's gambit
you did but slow motion replay
or that was kind of fast motion but
this did emerge from a king's gambit
thank you broom
ruby aloe subbing for three months
okay she saw my my porking threat
so i could play this move
uh move all the way back d5 i have c4
if rook here i i fork like this
i need check i take the knight so
discoveries don't work
oh but she has a counter pin
and then i deflect it's getting
complicated
wow how's this working
let's just move over threatening the
rook and threatening this
looks tied down to the night
should be winning
am i not meeting it's close to mate
solid move
not seeing meat
wow that was a tactic
she had meat there dirty flag time
that's going to be a draw maybe
that's a draw what was that game oh i
have a good position and then i lost all
my material
no oh everyone say their favorite
opening
yeah what should i play as black
nimsovich okay i'll play knight c6
that was the first thing i saw
how do i play this opening d6
d6 carlson played this once
it just kind of transposes to a pierce i
guess
ah she's gonna go for the stuff
so
i usually don't play this um i guess e5
is logical
uh this move
i don't know what i'm doing here you
guys should queenside castle
it's also this move no
i usually like to play this sort of
battery thing as white
um i'll play a6
okay trying to not get crushed in the
opening
also trying to launch some attack
before coming maybe
pinning the thing
losing a pawn kind of
but every pawn lost as the file opened
okay we could take and play this move if
ever
f4 then my bishop gets really really
happy
so ooh
i'm not sure if i want to take right
away i might leave the tension
for a moment there's a cool mating idea
a3 takes and then bishop b2 mates
i'm going to go for it so if takes i
take your threatening
yeah oh it doesn't work she's gonna play
bishop d4
so i'll play c5 fur
first i don't know
not seeing how this works i'll play this
queen d6
no my time i'm trying to figure out how
to mate
take their
rook a6 just like a quiet move i want to
defend the pawn
and the event of c5 takes takes
oh
i'm sacking kind of
hey eric hey
how's it going i don't know what to do
here
why is my mouse mouse keeps dying too
what's this
wait i'm down a piece no
my queen no ah she sees it
that's unfortunate
okay double attack knights oh but
knight's going to defend the other
nights
[Music]
play this move
play this move
yeah we'll play
ah my rook she could have taken it
actually
i was trying to be too creative that
game no okay
all i need is one draw to like clinch
this match
okay um let's play one of these again
uh yeah i'll play c3 sicilian
um yeah she's playing a lot of uh these
kind of
oh what does this move b6
i can take and then trap a rook
hey it's an opening trap winning
winning material after five moves okay
it's a nice way to soothe the pain of
the previous game
that's a really weird opening trap
yeah that's why like the combination of
b6 and d6 is not
i guess recommended
but it's good to like experience this
this type of thing once and then
uh like hopefully from her perspective
she won't fall into this again
oh she wants to trap my queen um
i don't think my queen is getting
trapped knight 26 i have this move
that was a nice kind of puzzle position
because not every day you just put your
queen in black's territory
so quickly
also thank you robidope13 subbing with
prime
um bishop here
the queen has no moves currently
but it should be okay
let's start with this move
because this is really the only way to
attack it and then i take the pawn
now i can probably develop somehow
get the rook to d1
but yeah i mean this is what black
should be doing is
trying to create some some ounce of hope
oh is there a prediction prediction
whether i'll win
the match in this game
it's looking promising but can never let
my guard down
wait a minute my queen getting trapped
takes takes i could take and then the
bishop's pinned
and meanwhile i'm creating some
[Music]
counter play
[Music]
oh
how to do this
my queen might actually get trapped
though
i have to play this and
bishop's still pinned i don't know how i
kind of let this happen i guess i got
too complacent
uh if i take on d6
wait a minute
yeah takes
not seeing it let's try this and rook d1
so now the bishop's into the rook and
i'm fighting this
i might just lose this though
this is really bad
take on c5
how much material do i have
wait maybe it's not so bad is this bad
wait oh no box queen okay
wait how am i i'm up a pawn what just
happened there
i'm up upon up on time too
so i lost my queen but then somehow it
worked out
okay let's just not flag this game
and go for the fork
okay knight d5 coming
there we go okay that was a weird game i
think i was losing at some point
was that game um
yeah it was weird because uh
like here the queen's trapped but the
bishop's trapped and then it comes with
a fork
okay um
how bad was it i think i'm losing around
here
yeah i'm losing around here
and then
oh so bishop a6 was a blunder yeah black
just has to
only move to wins c takes b4
because b4 was uh the trickiest move
okay we're gonna hop on call
nemo hello good games our last opening i
played was so troll
yeah it's uh i was telling my chat it's
usually not a good idea to combine
b6 and d6 yes
somehow i still managed to trap your
queen but i then i just blundered after
the whole thing that was really weird
yeah i was uh i was flustered because i
thought it was going to be an easy win
and then out of nowhere out of nowhere
my queen was getting trapped and
yes had to pull off some desperate moves
it was pretty cool though i mean he's
still got the end game up a pawn
so definitely not a line i want to play
in the future
yeah if you're gonna play d6 on move two
then i don't want to i'm i'm gonna i'll
i know how to play the island
it's just i never expect people to play
c3 so i usually already have d6 play
so oh interesting okay yeah it's just
one of those pre-move things that
you always gotcha yeah i'm trying i've
been trying to mix up the
openings as much as possible and take
advantage of things like that
same i mean i think i think this time
went a lot better than last time i
didn't even like prepare any of the
openings
really against you but like it just felt
like you were avoiding some certain
lines
yeah i feel like you you've definitely
played a lot better this time
or maybe i got worse i don't know but i
think let's go with
i got better so it feels both of us feel
better you know
yeah your openings seem like they were
improved like you just played more
quickly
it seemed like you were more confident
um with not taking too much time and
a lot of games you had time advantages
and it was harder to get
you into like opening traps apart from
this last game
but uh yeah i was very impressed with
like a lot of your play
a lot of games that i won even you you
probably should have won
it came down to yes there's a lot of
games where the in the time scramble
it just it became so crazy actually i
really like that
yeah that's the case with uh i guess
with no increments then a lot
it can come down to dirty flagging if uh
if
either of us uh gets too low but makes
it entertaining
yeah i think it was really good i think
the games were honestly pretty high
quality
and like it was just like the tactics
was really crazy
i i really like that part when i play
against it oh definitely yeah and uh
i think it was at the second to last
game i tried to fake
and oh no my queen i let you just take
my queen but
i did it and i was like oh my god okay
because i actually you
you owned your rook once and i got
checkmated so now i'm learning
uh yeah you should always think twice
before taking what looks like free
material
exactly i think that is definitely not
just for chat it's all mostly for me
yeah i mean it's good for uh it's good
kind of life lesson not everything in
life is free
so for sure well do you want to move on
to uh